it is relentless and it is perilous but
there is no way to escape it a
slow-moving weather system now sits on
northern Mozambique turning roads into
torrents and small streams in two major
obstacles the aid agencies have arrived
with supplies and expertise but the rain
is disrupting their activities
yes very frustrating because we are
ready to hard we have everything ready
and we know that people need this food
and we can't bring it so this very
frustrating force in a neighborhood code
TT in the city of Pemba main street has
turned into a creek an unofficial
waterway that's been created by five
days of torrential rain everybody here
has suffered with one resident comparing
it to a tsunami the rest and aura it was
really devastating rain the wall of the
stadium and then the water flowed down
here it has destroyed so many houses in
our neighborhood the winds from cyclone
Kenneth took the roofs off while the
floodwaters have destroyed the walls
35,000 homes have been lost
the government has advised their owners
to move to higher ground but the people
of tt don't want advice they want
assistance what happened here
Kevin Sharkey what is happening here is
that we're not receiving any aid nothing
at least nothing in this neighborhood so
we're just trying to help each other
we've been stopped several times by
residents who are really angry that the
government has done not
here in their community and they want a
guarantee from us that we will bring the
government or the aid agencies down here
to help them out it's difficult for us
to make promises the aid agencies are
stretched this is the second major storm
system to hit the country in the past
six weeks and they simply cannot reach
some communities like ebo it's still
raining and unfortunately the second
helicopter flights the World Food
Program is not able to take off to ebo
where people are really desperate for
food it has been raining since the
cyclone and the houses have been
completely destroyed
normality has been swept away by these
ad hoc urban rivers and it will take
months or even years to recover John
Sparkes Sky News in Pemba